So today, uh, we will
talk about the bluest eye.
Yeah.
This novel has a lot to do
with the questions that John
Barth was thinking about
in a very different register
in lost in the fun house.
This is of course the story of a little
girl who is totally remade by a story
that's told to her.
And I just want to point this out to you.
On page one 82 of the bluest eye.
This is the letter that,
so pet church rights to
God explaining his action.
Um,
he has remember tricked Pichola into
thinking that if something happens to the
dog that he sends her out to feed,
uh,
it will be a sign that God has
answered her prayer for Blue Eyes.
And of course what she's given,
uh,
what he has given her to
give to the dog is poisoned.
So of course the dog dies
and this convinces Pichola
that her prayers have been
answered and it pushes her
over the edge into, uh,
into something like schizophrenia.
But so pet is very
satisfied with his work.
And this is how he describes that work.
I looked at that ugly little black
girl and I loved her. I played you.
He says to God, and it
was a very good show. I,
I have caused a miracle.
I gave her the eyes,
I gave her the blue, blue
to blue eyes, cobalt blue,
a streak of it right out of your own
blue heaven. No one else will see her,
uh,
her blue eyes,
but she will and she will
live happily ever after.
I have found in meat and right.
So to do that last line meet and rights,
so to do is from the Anglican Liturgy or,
uh,
I may also occur in the Catholic liturgy.
Um,
it refers to the last supper. Uh,
it is meat and rights, so to do,
to commemorate Christ's last supper
with his disciples through the,
the sacrament of the Eucharist.
So he makes that story.
He tells her one into a sacramental
story as if he is giving her God's gift.
But it is very patently a story.
And we get that because he says
she will live happily ever after.
So what he has invited her to do is to
fully inhabit the dream of the white
aesthetic that her mother has absorbed
through the movies and has used in naming
her.
Remember in the novel were told that um,
pechal his name is close to a name
from the 1934 movie imitation of life,
which was a,
it has a complicated story,
but it's about race relations and it
features a little girl named Payola who
ends up passing for white because she
so hates the blackness of her mother.
So pet cola is mother
absorbed that white aesthetic,
projected it onto her daughter and her
daughter finally so longs to inhabit that
story that she goes to.
So pet church,
and this is how she ends up and the
cost of inhabiting that story is
derangement.
If John Barthes characters
inhabit stories,
stories that preceded them in the world,
remember this is why it's important that
the narrator of the first story in that
collection is the sperm.
The sperm comes already stocked with
the phrases and patterns of prior
literature.
Well,
Toni Morrison advances and
analysis that is not so different.
Pichola came into the world essentially
through her mother and the society that
surrounded her stocked with
the story of white aesthetics.
The story that told her that she and
her family were ugly and irredeemable.
The quality of Morrison's fiction could
not be more different from the quality
of Barthes fiction.
And I want to suggest to you that
that's because in Morrison's fiction,
this is her first novel begun in the
early sixties published in 1970 in this
novel.
She is absorbing something
from that sixties culture
reflecting on it that Barth
kept very much at arm's length.
So the abstract question of what kinds
of narratives produce the identity of a
person becomes for Morrison.
A political question.
Remember that divide I was
describing in 1960s um,
political in the 1960s political world
where some activists by the mid sixties
began to drop out of activism because
they were convinced that it was more
important to know themselves then to
actually go and try to promote a positive
program in the world.
And there was the
counterculture gaining steam,
advocating a playful engagement with
the world that would be uninterested in
questions like the Vietnam War.
Turn your back on the wars
has says Ken Keasy drop out,
drop acid.
That's the thing you should be doing.
Well,
the cultural politics of the late
sixties try to merge these two kinds of,
uh,
resistance to convention.
So it merges the cultural
focus of the counterculture.
That's why it's called
the counter culture.
It produces a culture against the
prevailing culture and that politically
activist body of thought coming out of
the civil rights movement and the black
power movement in the 60s
so this produces a cultural politics,
the cultural politics of the late sixties
and into the 70s and I would say even
up through the culture wars of the,
of the 1990s this is the legacy
of the 1960s in literature.
So Morrison takes the insights of Barth
and she turns them to political purpose.
One of our questions today is going to
be why does Tony Morrison in 1970 sit
down to write a novel instead of a tract?
Why is she interested in literature as
opposed to something like sociology?
She has such a strong and passionate
desire for justice for African Americans.
Why is literature her chosen venue?
Now I'm sure there are a thousand reasons,
but we're going to,
I'm going to bring some of them out of
the novel that we can read right there.
Just without going into
biography or psychology,
we're going to think about how the novel
presents itself as doing a kind of work
in the world that Barthes
writing never tries to do.
So.
That's where I'm going to go today.
Let me also point out that like pension
Morrison wants to imagine the novel as a
medium that can hold the human within it.
So a second question that I want to
get at today is given that commonality,
remember I ended my lecture on pension
by arguing that sentiment remained
important in pensions work
despite all that word play,
all that self conscious
irony of the story,
all that humor at the level of names.
What really finally mattered
was not that search for meaning,
but the moment when you could touch
another human being and pension is
interested in certain kinds of essences
like dandelion wine or tears or the
sailors mattress that hold in them in
suspension the cycles and movements of
human life.
Morrison has that same desire
to hold the human in her fiction
and so this is one reason why
Morrison chooses the novel.
This is the first of the reasons to hold
the human in suspension in the novel
now takes a very particular form and if
you think to the passages about Pauline,
there's the section on
Piccolos mother Pauline,
where we see large blocks of
Italics of her voice coming to us.
This is a very obvious example of
how that works in Morrison's fiction.
This is an effort to let the voice of
the unheard speak through her fiction,
so why write a novel instead of writing,
attract or becoming a
sociologist or a politician?
One reason for Morrison is that the novel
allows the voices of the oppressed to
speak in a way that they
could not otherwise.
This entails a certain assumption
about her own position as a writer.
She writes from within a black community,
she knows well,
this novel is set in
Lorain, Ohio, her hometown,
and so she takes on that task because
she feels she is equipped for it.
She can speak in a communal voice or
she can make her voice available for the
voices within the community
that she knows. Now,
how many of you have
read beloved? Ah, great.
I usually don't put it on the syllabus
because I assume most people have read it,
but if you recall,
this effort to recover the voice of
the unheard is absolutely central to
beloved.
It is the premise of beloved.
Tony Morrison found an account of a woman
in a newspaper in the mid 19th century
who tried to kill her children instead
of allowing them to be recaptured into
slavery.
And she thought about what kind of story
that woman would have to tell about her
life or what kind of story could be told
about that woman that the papers that
historians would never know and would
never be able to recover fiction because
it is imaginative,
gives you a way to get at what academics
have the traditional kind cannot
transmit about the past,
but also in this novel
about a life that is more,
that is closer to her current moment.
The moment of writing.
Yeah.
So by including Pauline's voice,
she allows Pauline to begin to tell her
own story of how she became married to
Charlie Breedlove and how she evolved
into the fairly hateful woman that we see
her to be when we see
her as Piccolos mother
you might find,
and I have to admit,
I myself find that particular example
quite clunky in a literary sense.
Why did Morrison suddenly turned
to those Italic sized blocks?
And I don't know if you read the, I
think you have the, the um, postscript,
the afterward that Morrison appended
to this edition of the novel.
If you haven't read it, I would suggest
that you do. It's quite interesting.
She notes there that she herself is very
unhappy with that section of the novel.
She herself finds it Clunky from
the perspective of 20 years later.
She writes the afterword in 1993
so it's unsatisfying to her,
but there are more successful versions
of it and you see that, for example,
when the women are gathered around aunt
Jimmy's bed in there talking as she is
in her final sickness and they're talking
with one another about their aches and
pains. That's one example of how
those voices come into the novel.
There are, there are just
many dozens of these examples,
so anytime you hear a
character begin to speak,
you have that sense that you're hearing
something that you wouldn't otherwise
hear if Morrison was not there to open
your ear to it and to embody those
voices.
It's one of the great strengths of her
writing is that ability to embody the
voice.
So that's one reason why you write a
novel instead of being a sociologist.
Another reason is to push the
boundaries of what's credible,
to push those boundaries so far that
you can see the abject very clearly in
front of you within a literary form.
And so,
uh,
she chooses Pichola as the ugly child.
She seems to have no
redeeming intelligence.
She has no one who really loves her except
maybe a few whores who live above her
house.
Um,
she has no conversation
that we really recall.
She doesn't say anything
particularly witty.
Probably what we remember her for is
simply that desire to have blue eyes.
We don't really get inside her head even.
And so this is a place where Morrison's
desire to speak for those who can't
speak for themselves,
runs up against a wall,
but she's very interested in what happens
when the imagination hits up against
that wall.
How far can we go towards inhabiting the
subject position of an abject person?
That's what she's testing in this novel.
And she herself speaks of a
silence at the heart of it.
And that silence is in part the silence
about Piccolos experience of the rape
when she's raped by her father. We don't
really get a sense of what she thinks,
what she experiences.
If you think,
again back to Barth,
remember that quotation of silence
at the very center of mental ad.
So Morrison is again engaging a problem
that other writers are engaging at this
time,
but she's setting it in a very specific
historical moment with very specific
historical and political connotations
and implications coming out of her
examination.
So silence is at the heart but it's
hedged around so that we can see it as a
silence.
So extremity does that for her.
I would argue that
the third reason she uses
the novel instead of attract
is to generate sympathy.
And this again I was arguing
is part of pensions project.
Usually someone like Morrison is separate
in people's categories of contemporary
fiction from writers
like Barth and pension.
I'm going to argue that they actually
occupy much of the same space.
What does sympathy look like in Morrison?
Well,
she sets herself a task that I would
say is almost as hard as the task that
Novakof has set himself.
And in fact maybe it's
even harder back off.
Set himself the task of making
us like Humbert Humbert.
Now,
how many of you like temper in the end?
He's getting less popular as
the, as the weeks go by. Um,
more of you seem to like him when we were
in the, in the throes of reading his,
his seductive voice,
but Nebraska off set himself the task
of seducing us with Humberto Voice
Morrison as part of this novel,
sets herself the task of making us
sympathize with a drunk who has no verbal
capacities.
Who raped his own daughter.
Now, does she succeed? Well,
let's, let's take a look
on page one 46 we get,
we're a little ways into the
story of Charlie Breedlove
and this is in the scene
where
he has just left the funeral of his aunt
with a girl named Darlene and they're
playing and flirting and a
and making out in the field.
She's gotten her clothes dirty.
You ain't dirty. He says to
her, I am to look at that.
She dropped her hands from the ribbon
and smoothed out of place on her dress
where the grape Steen's were heaviest.
Charlie felt sorry for her.
It was just as much his fault.
Suddenly he realized that aunt Jimmy
was dead for he missed the fear of being
whipped.
There was nobody to do it except uncle
Oh v and he was the bereave to let me,
he said, and he rose. He
said he rose to his knees,
facing her and tried to tie her ribbon.
Darlene put her hands under his
open shirt and rub the damp skin.
When he looked at her in surprise,
she stopped and laughed.
He smiled and continued nodding the bow.
She put her hands back under his shirt.
These little gestures that Morrison
grants to Charlie in this scene,
tiny gesture of tying the girls bow,
leaning over her,
concerned for her looks as
she goes back to her mother,
telling her,
reassuring her that she's not dirty and
in a novel that is so full of demonized
cleanliness,
his gentle assurance that her dress,
those stained is not
dirty in the moral sense.
This is a mark of kindness,
a mark of humanity.
So Morrison begins with small details
like this to build up our sympathy for
Charlie.
It gets more intense when
he meets his father in,
uh, in the city. This is on page one 55.
This is when he first
sees him, uh, playing
craps in the alleyway.
Yeah.
Amanda, the Light Brown jacket
stood at the far end of the group.
He was gesturing in a quarrelsome
agitated manner with another man.
Both of them had folded their faces
in anger, Charlie edge round two,
where they stood hardly believing
he was at the end of his journey.
There was his father,
a man like any other man,
but there indeed were his eyes, his
mouth, his whole head, his shoulders,
lurch, alert. Beneath that
jacket, his voice, his hands,
all real.
They existed really existed
somewhere right here.
Charlie had always thought of
his father is a giant of a man.
So when he was very close,
it was with a shock that he discovered
that he was taller than his father.
In fact, he was staring at a
balding spot on his father's head,
which he suddenly wanted to stroke.
While this fascinated by the pitiable
clean space hedged round by neglected
Tufts of wool, the man turned to
hard, belligerent face to him.
And then he assumes that Charlie has come,
uh,
at the behest of a woman that he slept
with two to squeeze money out of it.
Hmm.
So in this scene,
we once again see that humane touching
impulse.
He wants to touch his father's head,
touch the sign of his father's mortality.
The fact that his father's growing older,
he sees in his father's body,
his own face, hands, voice,
and we can feel that with him.
And then when he flees from that
scene finally and soils himself,
he becomes another one of those abject
characters you go as to hide under a
pier.
Finally bathes in a river at night.
This kind of detail gives us two things,
both the beginnings or another iteration
of the reason why he becomes who he
becomes,
the drunk,
the rapist.
But it gives us more than that.
It gives us a sense of his complexity.
It makes us want to like him.
And in fact, by this point,
I would argue that probably most of, uh,
most readers do like him at this point
in the novel.
Ken Morrison Sustain this
to the very end. Well, in a
way I want you to be the judge.
But if we look on two oh six,
I would argue that we're
beginning to see that effort.
This at the very end
of the novel,
speaking of Pichola,
oh some of us loved her and
that love is in quotations,
the Maginot line.
And Charlie loved her.
I'm sure he did.
He at any rate was the one who
loved her enough to touch her.
Enveloper give something
of himself to her.
But his touch was fatal in
the something he gave her,
filled the matrix of her agony with death.
Love is never any better than the lover.
Wicked people love wickedly
violent people love violently weak.
People love weekly stupid
people love stupidly.
But the love of a free man is never safe.
There is no gift for the beloved.
The lover alone possesses
his gift of love.
The loved one is shorn,
neutralized,
frozen in the glare of the lovers inward.
I
for one thing,
Morrison and Dow's these sentences with
a lyrical quality that makes us feel
their power,
but there's one line she uses to describe
Charlie that I think trumps all the
others and that's this one
about the love of a free man.
The love of a free man is never safe.
Safety is not exactly a value
in this novel.
If it were the safe white household in
which Mrs Breedlove works would look a
lot more appealing than it does.
Yeah,
there's a certain safety for Frida
and Claudia in their intact household,
but there too.
It is fraught with suffering.
Their mother is cruel to them.
She yells at the safety is not really to
be had there and the safety that is had
comes at great cost when
Charlie is described as having
freed himself earlier in
the novel.
Part of that story,
which we don't get explicitly,
is that he has learned to turn his
hatred finally against the white men,
symbolized by the white men who
discover him making love to Darlene.
In that earlier scene,
we're told that initially he hates her
instead of the white men because hating
the white men would undo him to such
an extent he was not ready to see that
oppression for what it was later in his
life were told he kills three white men.
We don't know the circumstances,
and at that moment we're
told that he's a free man.
Freedom when applied to a black man
cannot be a wholly negative quality in the
context that Morrison evokes of a
society still plagued by the remnants of
slavery to call Charlie free
can't be to dismiss him.
It gives a certain honor
and weight to his anger.
Okay.
And to revoke that word,
to come back to that word in
describing his love for the daughter,
he rapes I think is quite controversial.
It suggests that there was some value
in the thing of himself he gave to her.
Yeah.
Now this is not exactly what you'd
want to call a feminist position,
although Morrison certainly is,
I would say a feminist writer in
the largest sense of that word.
But what she has tried to
do here in keeping with the
challenge that I think she
must have set for herself,
is to make us see Charlie complex,
Lee enough to sympathize with him
even after he commits this crime.
So she takes a certain kind of risk,
but that's why she does it.
She wants us to see him
in a sympathetic light.
This is what a novel can do.
It requires that lyrical quality of voice.
It requires the buildup of history,
and it requires in this scene,
the return to that precise language.
So a very common literary technique.
We see it all the time in the things
that we read together is to return to the
terms you use in an earlier moment to
ring the changes on those terms. Again,
to use that word well,
that's what Morrison uses to produce
this sense of value in Charlie at the end
of the novel.
In this sense,
it participates or is in conversation
with a tradition of the 19th century novel
in America.
So one of the most prestigious novels
of the 19th century is of course,
Harriet Beecher Stowe
is uncle Tom's cabin.
Hugely successful novel abolitionists
novel whose aim was to create a sense of
the slave's humanity for white readers
so that white readers would become
inspired to the abolitionist cause.
Okay.
What was repulsive about that novel to
someone like Morrison is the starched
white virtue and the starched white
culture to which the African American
characters in the novel were recruited.
So in that novel,
their humanity and the sympathy that that
would evoke from the reader dependent
on they're looking as white as possible.
And therefore there was this, uh,
great privileging of the light
skinned black in that novel
and a sense of Christian value
redeeming the darker skinned characters.
They needed it more, it seems,
than the light skinned characters.
So the darker your skin is in uncle
Tom's cabin, the more religious you are.
Yeah.
So it's a whitewashing
of the African American figure.
So Morrison takes something
of the sympathetic project
of uncle Tom's cabin and
that tradition of the 19th century novel,
but she transforms it by making us
sympathetic to someone like Charlie,
who Harriet Beecher Stowe would put
so far outside the Pale of humanity.
We wouldn't,
he wouldn't even be visible on her screen.
Yeah.
So this is her project.
Sympathy,
however,
relies on some darker and more ambiguous
techniques that Morrison is also
committed to. And one of those is
what I'm going to call negativity.
Morrison is very,
uh,
careful in this novel especially
to talk about what people are not.
And you see an example of this on page
55 when she's describing the prostitutes.
Yeah.
This is after she's been telling stories.
A Marine Ms. Murray has been telling
stories to Pichola about her husband.
They did not belong.
This is at the bottom of the page.
They did not belong to those generations
of prostitutes created in novels with
great and generous hearts dedicated
because of the horror of circumstance to
ameliorating the luckless bear in life
of men taking money incidentally and
humbly for their understanding.
Nor were they from that sensitive breed
of young girl gone wrong at the hands of
fate,
forced to cultivate an outward bitterness
in order to protect her springtime
from further shock.
But knowing full well she was cut out for
better things and could make the right
man happy.
Neither were they the sloppy,
inadequate whores who are unable
to make a living at it alone.
Turn to drug consumption and traffic or
pimps to help complete their scheme of
self destruction.
Avoiding suicide only to punish the memory
of some apps and father or to sustain
the misery of some silent mother except
for Maria's fabled love for Dewey
prints. These women hated
men. All men without shame,
apology or discrimination.
They abuse their visitors with a
scoring grown mechanical from youth use,
black men, white men, Puerto Rican,
Mexican Jews, Poles, whatever.
All were inadequate and weak.
All came under their jaundiced eyes
and we're the recipients of their
disinterested RAF.
They took delight in cheating
them on one occasion.
The town well knew they lured a Jew up
the stairs, pounced on him. All three,
held him up by the heels,
shook everything out of his pants
pockets and threw him out of the window.
Neither did they have respect for women
who, although not their colleagues,
so to speak, nevertheless deceived
their husbands regularly or irregularly.
It made no difference.
Sugarcoated whores.
They called them and did not
yearn to be in their shoes.
They're only respect was for what they
would have described as good Christian
colored women. The women whose
reputation was spotless and two,
tended to her family, the woman, sorry,
whose reputation was spotless and who
tended to her family who didn't drink or
smoke or run around. These women had
their undying, if covert affection,
they would sleep with their
husbands and take their money,
but always with a vengeance.
Nor were they protective and
solicitous of youthful innocence.
They look back on their own youth as a
period of ignorance and regretted that
they had not made more of it.
They were not young girls
in Horace clothing or whores
regretting their loss of
innocence.
There were whores in horse clothing
whores who had never been young and had no
word for innocence whores
in whores clothing.
That's the negativity,
one version of the negativity.
It refuses all those conventional stock
stories of what horse can be in the
novel. So the very first instance
of it singles out the novel,
they did not belong to those generations
of prostitutes created in novels with
great and generous hearts and so on.
But all those other versions are
equally fictional types of prostitutes.
Yeah,
so she rejects the stock.
Literary cupboard
have stories about prostitutes.
They were whores and whores clothing.
There is an assertion of
their opacity right there.
They are opaque to literary embellishment.
They are what they are.
They just are whores.
But the negativity,
the repeated knorrs,
neither were they this nor were
they that they were not this,
they were not that it is a kind of engine
of narrative and it limbs the place
where they might come to stand in and
of themselves without embellishment.
So the effort to help us to
sympathize with marginal characters,
Charlie Breedlove prostitutes
is an effort at limbing,
a space where they can stand in and of
themselves and it creates narrative for
us to sympathize through.
It creates a credibility for her voice.
It creates a sense of where
they can occupy a space.
These characters.
Yeah.
What's more Murray,
as we know,
is the one person who really
tells stories in this novel.
So Morrison also gives her a
special gift as a character,
a gift that Morrison's own gift echos.
She's allowed to tell stories for pickles,
delight.
She's the only one who does that
sort of thing for this child.
Okay.
Pichola herself though,
is the ultimate negativity and this
is on two oh five you can see how this
works.
Yeah,
this is in the B. In the middle
of that page, all of our waste,
which we dumped on her in which
she absorbed all of our beauty,
which was hers first,
and she gave to us all of us all
who knew her felt so wholesome.
After we cleaned ourselves on her,
we were so beautiful.
When we stood a stride, her ugliness,
her simplicity decorated us.
Her guilt sanctified us.
Her pain made us glow with health.
Her awkwardness made us think
we had a sense of humor.
Her inarticulateness made
us believe we were eloquent.
Her poverty kept us generous,
even her waking dreams.
We used to silence our own nightmares
and she let us and thereby deserved our
contempt. We honed our
egos on her, padded,
our characters with her frailty and
yawned in the fantasy of our strength.
Pichola is the embodiment of the negative,
so she represents all that.
The community does not want in
itself the excess blackness,
the ugliness that the white aesthetic
says can't be changed or redeemed.
She represents the poverty that they all
strive to escape or at least keep us at
bay.
So Piccola as the negativity is through
the whole novel and the structure of the
whole novel, the absence that
keeps the narrative engine working,
it has to keep working because she's
always there as the negative pole
waiting to be touched even in the
least bit by the narratives revelation.
Yeah,
so she embodies that.
The desire to know another person,
which in men Alayah if you'll
remember is mentally is his undoing.
He did doubles on and on
his voice asking why, why?
Why did you choose me, Helen? Why? Why
do you love me? He can't take any answer
and it makes him ridiculous
and it ruins his marriage.
That effort to know another person is
much more than a diddling on in Morrison.
That effort to know another person
isn't by definition put off limits in
Morrison.
The effort at trying as far more honored,
the alienation from self,
which produces a kind of irony and a
pleasure in humor in both Barth and
pension.
That self consciousness that you see in
both novels is not a source of humor in
Morrison because the alienation
is produced by an unjust society.
It's not a laughing matter.
It's not so much the universal
human condition as it is
in Barth to be alienated
from yourself.
The self alienation that Piccola in
bodies as the negative is the product of
oppression,
racial oppression.
If there is
an opportunity for humor
in Morrison's work,
it's not going to come from
that fountain of, of irony.
So is is irony dead in Morrison?
Well maybe if we see
irony in Morrison's work,
it's in the specific local
language of the characters.
And I would submit to you that
where we see something funny,
it's always with a tinge
of darkness as in um,
Claudia and freed mother
when she complains,
I dunno if you remember this scene when
she complains about Pichola drinking all
the milk.
She goes on and on and on in this
Baroque Aria of of indictment,
and it's funny and what we're told about
this mother is that on her grumpy days,
this is what she does.
She complains about the whole world
until she got everything covered.
She's covered every complaint she could
possibly have and then she sings and the
fact that she turns to singing after
having done that suggests a kind of
continuity that there's an operatic
artistic quality to the complaining and
Morrison gives it to us in her voice
and that is the kind of pleasure that
Morrison's novels give us.
Yeah.
That's the kind of humor
that her novels give us.
It's not going to be the funny,
sad situation of the
perpetually alienated Ambrose.
It's going to be a woman in her
kitchen who's out of milk now,
doesn't know where she's getting the next
court and yet and yet uses that verbal
facility to make something in its place,
in the place of the milk that's not there.
Something to entertain her
daughters as they listen.
So
there is a deeper even darker side I would
suggest to the generation of sympathy
in Morrison's novels.
And that's um,
the last point I want to make for you
today and I think we can see it most.
Well, I'm going to show you one example
and then quick flip to it to the more
important one on one 76 when,
so head reaches for his ink to
write his letter from to God.
Yeah.
A bottle of ink we are told was on
the same shelf that held the poison.
Writing and poison are
extremely close in this novel.
And what's more,
something like reading and being
raped are very close to one another.
And you can see this
on
in the conversation between Piccola
and her alienated other self.
That other voice keeps prodding
her about a second rape.
The second time keeps
saying the second time.
We are not shown that in the narrative.
So why is this something
that enters into it here?
The other voice says to her,
I wonder what it would be
like referring to the rape.
Horrible says Pichola his
voice. Really? Yes. Horrible.
Then why didn't you tell Mrs Breedlove?
I did tell her,
I don't mean about the first time.
I mean about the second time when
you were sleeping on the couch.
I wasn't sleeping.
I was reading.
Okay,
this is a weird moment.
You could read that as an od detail.
She really means that there was a second
rape and it happened not when she was
sleeping, although she'd said that before,
but when she was reading on the couch.
But I think there's a darker meaning
to this that it's actually the act of
reading that is folded in
to the act of being raped.
And this is not, I think foreign
to the whole setup of this novel,
that reading of that little passage.
Because of course,
as you will have noticed,
you have the Dick and Jane primary at
the beginning of each chapter made into
nonsense by being run together.
So remember in the first few pages of
the novel you have here is a house.
It is green and white. It has a red
door. It is very pretty. And then mother,
father,
Dick and Jane.
This is the white aesthetic
embodied in the primer.
The message is that when you learn to
read you our inbox in imbuing yourself,
imbibing the white aesthetic,
if you are a young black
girl learning to read,
you are bringing into yourself
a deadly kind of poison
and it's the poison that destroys pickle
his mother and Pichola herself in her
desire for the blue eyes.
Yeah,
the primers run together so that we can
see how it becomes nonsensical in the
context of Pichola his life,
but there is a profound indictment of
reading and so you have to ask yourself,
what kind of reader does Morrison want?
And this I think has a complex answer.
It is not just that Morrison wants
to indict a certain kind of reading
on the Dick and Jane Model.
It's deeper than that.
In her Nobel Prize winning speech,
she writes about her ideal reader.
Actually,
I think it's either in one of
her essays were in that speak.
In that speech she writes about her
ideal reader being what she calls the
illiterate reader.
By that she means the reader not
stocked up already with the imaginative
inventory of the western Canon.
Our reader,
who instead has some sense
of an oral tradition,
but there's more to it than that too.
Imagine a reader who is that poorly
prepared to meet a novel of the ambition
that Morrison's novels body.
If you read beloved,
without knowing how to close
read the way we do in class,
it's extremely hard to
get a lot out of it.
You were very difficult
passages in that novel.
She learned a lot from Faulkner.
That's one of the ways that she learned
to incorporate voices into her novel in
a way that they would sit by themselves
seemingly on mediated by a narrator.
She learned a lot from Virginia Woolf.
She wrote her m a thesis on Wolf and
Faulkner on suicide in wolf and Faulkner.
So she herself is highly educated,
deeply trained in the
modernist avant garde,
and yet she looks for a reader that has
rejected all of that that she calls on.
So skillfully
reading is such a vexed activity for
Morrison that she represents both reading
and writing as something like the
equivalent of being the victim of rape
that pushes the idea of sympathy
into another register altogether.
Yeah.
It's a text that is essentially
theorizing itself as reaching out to you,
not in the sense just of making you feel
like Charlie's and okay guy that he's
human and not some monster,
but actually reaching out to you and
doing to you what Charlie did to pick.
Hola.
That's an odd thing to
do to your own book.
So I want you to think about the kind of
reader that Morrison imagines and what
her novel is trying to
do within to that reader.
Um, I will come back to some of these
themes when we talk about woman warrior on
Wednesday.